it kind of came unexpected like someone
came from behind me my face turned
around another doesn't shock me that was
that good i mean
dms
dating ups i don't have time for that i
don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince i believe in
grilling them i'm gonna be going on a
series of dates to find who can really
wow me
this is thrilling
big toes mr cool now mr you know my
stomach is leaving your barber and i'm
not gonna let this i'm just here to see
what what she's about in person you know
i've seen a couple episodes a couple
videos but i'm trying to see if she can
handle me as well as i can handle it
tactics um just good eye contact good
conversation a bit of confidence you
know what i'm trying to say and that's
my style man first dates you know
they've all been successful you know i'm
trying to say but i haven't really found
someone that's really you know
made me excited like that maybe today
could be today today might be the day
you know we'll see we'll see we'll see i
love a challenge i love i love it man
you'll see in it you'll see for yourself
hello hello hello hello hello
nice to meet you merry christmas looking
nice in that red look nice and festive
thank you thank you thank you she's
looking sexy you know i'm not gonna lie
still i'm not gonna lie
i'm trying to keep my head you know what
i'm saying but yeah it's all mad thanks
standout tv nice little christmas gift
what's your name toby what you can call
me big tobes big types yes why big time
cheers you know my name is toby people
call me toast for sure call me big
because i'm quite big you know what i'm
saying so that's in hindi
what do you think
you want to start you want to stand up
and see
one you know i mean
good yeah yeah how are you feeling i'm
good you know i'm lacking a sentence i'm
liking my views that you know i'm saying
it's all good right now child mourinho
just saying honest truth i like an
honest man yeah i'm in trouble i know
um so tell me about you
so i'm a rapper i'm from east london
i've been rapping
seriously from about 2016. i was in it
for fun before and since 2016 i've kind
of been in the industry and just been
doing my thing since then that's not my
full-time career right now i do a bit
acting as well and a bit of fashion
stuff so what got you into music always
kind of loved the music as a kid i'll go
home go on the tv channel you mtv based
i never thought i was going to be a
rapper myself but i just loved what i
used to see and then when i was in
school i used to play about rapping like
in school my friends was like yeah
you're hard you're hard and i still
didn't take it seriously but then like
later on growing up a lot of my friends
in my area was doing music i started
joining them doing some little videos
and then i kind of got out there and
it's like well can i have i have to do
this tonight because everyone knows my
name through music and then now i'm here
big tubs what do you think he'd be doing
if he wasn't doing music
i used to be into basketball you know
really i used to play basketball
seriously like i went to france i was
living there playing there i went to
america i got a scholarship and all that
stuff i've always liked the look of a
basketball now what's your intentions
right now my intentions are always pure
i hope so grill men ask them questions
you have to grow me today yeah right you
can handle the game i think so you know
i just want to have a nice date though i
just have to grill me why can't you just
give me a nice day why do you go grow
before it depends on you and your five
minutes so yeah
if you bring good vibes then i'll be i'm
lacking your vibe so far you seem like a
nice girl a sweet girl but it's still
early so i'm going to siege you know
what i mean but yeah how are you going
to score me
is that i think i want i want to get to
know you though in it you know what i
mean i want to get to know you so what
you say to all the women no so i'm
saying to you right really yeah
are you a smooth talker do you think i'm
a smoothie yeah i just i just i just
talk naturally on the side if it comes
across as smooth maybe i'm a smooth tour
card or not i heard you're a bit of a
ladies man you know um
am i a ladies man
i love how that eye contact's now gone
she don't eat the norman i'm not like a
guy that like chats to bear girls and
tries to go on i'm not like that kind of
guy you know what i mean but so you say
bear girl says it just maybe you have
like three minimum nah i'm not really on
that in it but i've had my moment so i
used to chat to a lot of girls and stuff
like at the same time when you're single
you can do what you want right but i
just think that's a bit mad well you've
never like dated like more than one guy
at the same time no i genuinely i can't
because for me i just feel bad like one
is energy exchange like
i just hate the idea of someone else
doing that with multiple people so it's
kind of trick people you want to be
treated so imagine we're just talking
about getting to know each other and
we're just talking whatever but it's not
like i've told you i want to get with
you but like there's other people that
i've met and i'm talking to as well like
that's not that you think that's not
correct it's like you're just like
weighing out your options
but they're probably doing the same
thing though if i want to carry on
talking to you i'm not going to then
start pursuing someone else yeah it
makes sense now to be honest if you like
back in that day i was like that now i
don't have the time to invest in a lot
of people anyway would you say you'd be
a good husband 100 really i was in a
five-year relationship what would make
you a good husband
i've got good morals i'm respectful
i just know how to treat a woman you
know i'm going to say i'm patient he's
got a lot of substance about him
yeah takes a few boxes would you
sleep with a fan
no no no that's good now you see even me
when i go out and have fans like super
on me i run
like if i'm talking to a girl and she
she's a proper fan of me i'm not really
i'm not really trying to go
i didn't hear that then so oh
would you would you sleep with a rapper
no
where you know what it is okay i'm never
gonna say never yeah because you never
know but realistically like the
lifestyle i think
you'll be too much for me to handle
you like you obviously get a lot of
attention
and just many options like regular men
that aren't in like the media or
limelight they have options so imagine a
man that's also got options and in the
limelight that's not really fair you
know because not all rappers like do
this like bare girls and they're like
problem stuff like i'm like i'm you
don't hear not no scandalous stuff about
me
yeah you don't hear you don't see me
with bare women and stuff like that i'm
chilled so it depends because someone
can say you know yeah you do media you
have a lot of guys on your shows blah
blah blah so they don't give you a
chance but
i'm sure
i don't know what you're like do you
like see a lot of men or like well you
probably have a lot of options right
yeah but you're probably chilled yeah
are you yeah i'm well chill exactly so
you should give a rapper the same chance
man like me like you yeah they give you
a chance yes you get to know me and you
see beyond being a rapper in a public
eye you know i can't see beyond like i'm
not
a complete
when was the last time you had sex um is
that necessary to ask me that yeah and
all these people yeah i feel like
something is just kind of keep private
like you know i mean not really for the
whole world to know are you active or
just not active i'm not active do you
have like buddies and stuff buddies no i
don't feel about these
i know you think i'm lame i'm actually
being honest
what's your night in then i relax i've
got a studio in my house i might make
music every night it's kind of different
depends i might be busy i'm quite a busy
guy so it just depends on on that
evening
but again i was in a long relationship
so you know i mean and i kind of come
out
recently so i really like being kind of
chilling chilling do you think you're
going to like have a rebound and start
moving mad or you like
um no that's just women nowadays i don't
know about women ideas man i just don't
really want to invest in just anyone you
know i mean what's wrong with women
what is this toxic man why what they're
crazy the things i see and the things
that the way they act in it's just a bit
mad i don't know i don't
so i can kind of speak on it i just
think like the mentalities are a bit um
brainwashed by like city girls and stuff
like that and i feel like not a lot a
lot of women have good values nowadays
and they're influenced by the wrong
people a lot of the girls are acting
nowadays man they're just they're just
gassed in it i'm going to say but
they ain't really like that offline man
don't be don't be fooled by the hype
it's like a battle of the sexes
constantly no it is to be fair but it
seems like women hate men nowadays
anyway when i look online it's always
hate men descending so you guys all
preach oh we want a good woman that has
all these values but then it's okay for
you guys to then [ __ ] us up traumatize
us then we just think this why should i
be a good woman for the wrong men
because you just keep doing it that's
why this is why the world is finished
because it's like it's a back and forth
thing like you know what i'm trying to
say like so that's why it's a bit mad
but hopefully hopefully you know there's
there's good there's good women and good
men out there yeah 100 no one's
cancelled you know what i'm trying to
say well i'm just going to keep agreeing
with her man whatever in it
do you suffer with mental health i have
certain ways i might express myself like
through music i don't really talk to
people much but when i get on a mic and
i'm rapping i get to see everything
that's on my mind on my chest without i
can just put in the world so everyone
everyone knows how i'm feeling without
me having a personal conversation but
maybe that's something i need to work on
anyway do you know what i mean so what's
like your thoughts on like this home
just to be a man kind of thing and not
speak up on issues so i'll be ruled you
as a man it's hard to be vulnerable it's
hard to open up it's hard to seem like
you're weak in it i'm going to say and
and some women do take away that you
know i'm trying to say like when a man's
weak and vulnerable and it gets thrown
in your face and that's how a lot of men
feel so they feel like they can't really
and even to other mandate as well like
you don't want to see seen weak to other
guys as well so it's like you never want
to show that side and i feel like the
way men have been raised or a lot of men
being raised like it's almost like oh
get over it man you'll be like don't be
weak don't be like don't be a [ __ ] like
you're good so i feel like growing up in
that it's like we all feel like we you
have to get over it we're not going to
cry by what you crying for you know what
i'm going to say so i thought that's the
kind of mentality that most of us guys
have in it you know i mean most of the
deaths from men is like suicidal yeah
it's three and a half times higher than
women and that's probably because
monogamy things that he can't talk about
they've got no one to go to so they do
it for themselves and they're out there
might be drugs or they're out there
might be signing off that's killing them
you know i'm gonna say so i think it's
important for us to like i said therapy
man i've never done it but i've been
told by a lot of people that it's really
good you're not going to say and i feel
like a lot of men need to they need to
find another outlet to kind of
you know i'm saying they're not doing
for a long time because a lot of man's
died and it's like you didn't tell me i
didn't know who's going through this a
lot of us are holding a lot of things in
you get me so it's important to chat and
open up sometimes you feel me he's
speaking a lot of wisdom right now are
your dm's acting yeah but i don't open
it you stush
yeah yeah no shame oh it's quite booty
that's all right at least ain't got
nothing to worry about a lot of girls
they've messed up for rappers like they
messed up for themselves because like
all these screenshot business and oh i
talked to this person that i don't open
my dms you ain't gonna i don't respond
to you unless i know you or like you're
hitting me up on a purpose one like hey
i need to speak to you about or
something like that if you're just
hitting me up like this
i just i just i don't even open it some
men don't care in it someone's like
whatever in it about me i'm like yeah if
i'd have to see you out and like if i
see oh i'm revived then be viable you
know what i'm saying but there's bearcat
fishes on instagram that i am looking at
instagram picture thinking yeah yeah you
and then you know what i mean so if i
see or i like what you're doing on a
gram and i'm intrigued or i'm thinking
about it then i might have a little
conversation there and there and see
while gwan can catch up but i can
actually catch someone's vibe by looking
at their stories their highlights so you
kind of gauge
how a person isn't it so do you think
you brought up on love or survival both
really yeah love because i've been
around love like both of my parents like
my family you know i'm trying to say
like my friends like you know what i
mean by survival because i've been
through things outside that had to do
with by myself and then how to deal with
it by myself what's the hardest thing
you've had to do by yourself oh probably
when i got shot and stabbed you got shot
yeah and slashed my face can you see my
face
don't get scared though oh my god why
did you get a shot oh sh turkey man
people just tried to leave me and oh my
god they succeeded
yeah i've been for a lot of [ __ ] man
in my life but you know i'm here when
i'm cool you makes you stronger i'm here
i'm happy i'm healthy i'm living life
man so can't complain mommy move did you
ever think about your mom and your dad
because during situations when you get
into trouble like yeah i feel everyone's
so caught up in the moment like no one
actually thinks about like you could
have lost your life like 100 percent but
this wasn't a situation i expected like
i'm not a gang member i was not involved
in no gang violence but i got involved
in signing and people did sound bad to
me you know i'm going to say but i
didn't expect that to happen at the time
it kind of came unexpected like someone
came from behind me my face turned
around love doesn't shock me that was
that
i mean at the time my mom lived tonight
well my mom lives in that she lived in
nigeria since 2012 so she couldn't
really be there but i'm here today so
i'm thankful when i'm good i'm on a
beautiful day for beautiful girls so i'm
not trying nothing nothing too bad you
know i mean well thank you for sharing
that that's cool
cheers to
yeah big respect to him seems like he's
been for a lot and he's grown a lot and
i love a man that holds himself
accountable for things they've done
wrong do you have any fetishes um i love
toes and i'm joking i'm talking about
that is that why your friends did you
say your first uh ties or was it toast
are you violin no i'm just asking toes
or toes i thought they said i thought
you said that you're violent and you're
riding your body and you're violated
still about big toes
man size 11 but it's not big toes it's
big toes don't ever get cheeky like that
again
toes you know
yeah
i don't know i don't care about them i
don't know that's not my favorite
rubbish what is your fish and by the way
feet are nice now i feel cool but i just
don't care but i'm like i'm not going to
suck them ever i'm not going to lick
them i'm not going to lie i might
massage it if your feet are clean but so
what's your fetish then do i have a
fetish like that
i really like curly hair you know do you
see that's not weird is it it's just i
feel that's more like a preference it's
not like that's not fair unless you're
typing like curly hair porn something is
that a thing
i don't know
do you watch porn no i don't at all no
you don't watch people i used to but i
don't
everyone watches poor man she's
definitely watching poor man he must be
getting in that's why isn't it
yeah yeah cause it stops you from like
going to see your god i don't want to
see you oh really it's that's how you do
it
you get me just do your thing then
you're cool you can sleep nice because
you know sometimes when you're horny uh
you might go for your phone thinking
there's so much girls that are thinking
yeah i can go hit her up but you don't
want to do that because you're going to
have sex and you're probably going to
regret after put on a little pawn and
just release whatever you need to
release you know i'm saying but it's not
often though sometimes okay
what do you want out live
have a a good family good home my whole
family my friends to be looked after
i want to leave this world of a legacy
just good positive things you know i'm
trying to say like rest in peace my boy
cadet like everyone's got good things to
say about cadet he was my guy my one of
my closest mates and so i just want to
leave behind a good a good legacy man
yeah what i'm saying yeah do you have
any insecurities
no you know have you always been
confident no
when i was growing up i was not
confident at all i was i was just i was
a kid in secondary school i'd just be
hiding my face like this in the corner
like just just kind of just chilling was
you shy that was proper sure even though
i'm scared i'm i'm a bit shy about i
think doing music helped me overcome
that because when you got to get on a
stage and trying to bear people you
can't be shy in it you have to do the
kind of things like and that kind of
helped
line for a good five years i was like hi
i'm cheyenne and there's nothing shy
about me
oh my god no you don't seem to turn nah
i was just ugly though like yeah i was
so butters in school show me a picture
no
no you were you went ugly i swear to god
i was what she you oh you brought it up
i swear to god anyone from school will
tell you i was collapsed i don't care i
went to school in essex okay i wouldn't
know yeah
why yes and no i've only um
done into one girl that i was in
relation with really i'd only do it in a
relationship so how can you sit with me
i'm a slept with
he clearly gets a lot of women
a few people in it a few yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but like a lot a little bit um what's a
lot to you any anything over like 50 in
it what's going to be around that you
know you've only literally gone down on
one woman yeah
can't just eat any yellow man come on
man
[Laughter]
why did all these men never go down on
women like what is the issue i was
proper against it like i actually said
i'll never ever ever do it i even had in
a song saying i'll never do it right one
of my biggest songs the song that blew
me up in that song i was like i'll never
do it it's 20 21 man you get me like
fingers change you get me
to all my friends i let you down so man
but um yeah
do you know what i just wasn't on that
like i just not was owning it but then i
got in a relationship and then you know
like
you gotta satisfy your goal in it when
she wants it you know i mean so i had to
just um
submit would you say you're good at it
though because you could have
it's not for me to say in it you know i
mean it's for her to say in it but yeah
i know what i'm doing in it you know i
mean yeah i'm doing yeah okay i've got a
job and i get a bedroom i've got a job
which is to make her finish you know i'm
saying so
okay
bro look at the way she's looking at my
soul well she's trying to seduce me she
knows what she's doing man and it's
working slowly you're not gonna lie
no no why not if you're my wife what's
mine is yours okay first of all you get
forget trust i'm not stuff there's
things there's conversations i might
have my boys there's a group chat
someone's in me with my bedrooms that
mine don't saying girls are nosy so girl
pick up my phone and she would want to
know oh everything about the drums and
say and there's certain things that
might not you want me to see yeah that
we should be we'll deserve some privacy
at the same time if i was in a
relationship with you and i asked to see
your phone yeah would you show me it
i'll see what you want to see first
memes memes
are you one of the people that send your
boyfriend like memes and stuff and all
this kind of stuff that you found funny
about that's how i flew out you said you
mean oh is it yeah are you a flirty girl
i think i'm i'm naturally a flirt but i
wouldn't even say that i'm flirting
you've got a very flirty like look don't
i don't think i tried i'm not trying to
be playing i know but you just gotta
look about your store it's good though
it's good to look like you yeah to look
like it's like a seductive kind of look
you know i mean maybe it's the red that
you're wearing
yeah i'm trying to seduce you it's the
small man it's a smile for me but um
yeah
um i just don't like leaving bad blood
didn't it unless like you dummy day if
you dummy day then we're not cool like i
don't want to see you if we just broke
up because we just broke up outgrow each
other yeah it'd be just i could still be
called you're not going to see it i find
it mad that you could spend years with
someone and just never speak to them
again
the world glamorizes oh my god that's
your ex you should hate them like nah
man you don't have to do that man
sometimes you outgrow people sometimes
you realize that person's not the one
for you don't mean you should hate each
other and start beefing each other like
she better see each other like you know
you're cool yeah you've got a nice guy
now we gotta make sure he looks after
you do you know what i'm trying to say
yeah simple
double standards red flag double
standards are mad like you can't be
active friends you could be cool as in
like if you're not saying but not like
active friendship you can't be like
talking all the time on a regular or
like having conversations yeah i i get
you i'm trying to say if you're if
you're cool with them like boom like it
might pop up hey cool yeah i'm blah blah
but as long as it's black boundaries in
it so i have an x that every few years
we actually catch up and go for dinner
well you must be high like yeah sniping
why are you gonna have for dinner i've
not been in a relationship
since
if that makes sense but we will
regularly catch up because it's just
nice to see the growth kind of thing i'm
not gonna lie if if i'm seeing someone
yeah
you're like you're not linking your ex
with dinners though that's not happening
what if it was just a coffee there not
today coffee burger chips is not opening
why because why are you doing that for
that's a date basically
once i'm done with someone i'm done like
i will never sleep with you again i will
never text you a flight away like so i
guess for me emotionally i'm so cut off
that i can actually go for dinner with
my ex and not fade away like i would not
even be attracted to him like it's
actually mad how disconnected i can be
when it comes to like relationships yeah
it's about how does he how would your
partner feel about things in it and
certain things you've got to sacrifice
for that so even though man no you're
gonna be good you're not trying to
you're not even attracted to them but
you genuinely want to see that see if
they're good if that's going to make
your partner feel a certain way or not
feel comfortable with it what's more
important to you like you're part you're
trying to grow a future with of course
you're man so it's like it's all certain
things you've got sacrifice like sound
like that like you probably wouldn't
want your guy to link with his ex for
dinner will you are you cool with that
no no there's something i'm very laid
back but at the same time i'm not an
idiot
you know so it depends on the person the
vibe the woman like the actor so a lot
of that goes goes into it you know i'm
trying to say unless me and your ex's
best friend which is probably not gonna
be happening then nah i feel like it's
unnecessary i feel like if you want to
check it out you can even the messages
might let that slide but not to actually
link them and spend time with them
it's gonna it's gonna cause deeper
issues that don't need to be to be you
know what i'm saying yeah
i've kind of accepted that people don't
know things in the past i can't really
let that affect
my relationship with them you know i'm
trying to say it but i'll prefer
if it was less i don't want to be in
places where like my man could have
no i'm saying that yeah i like it i like
exclusivity and all that kind of stuff
in it so
if your body counts
high now if it's really if it's really
high it's a normal goal in it do you
think it's like an amal ego thing
probably it's ego it's a new problem
maybe it is but it is what isn't it i
like what i like and if i prefer my goal
to be a lower body count than it is
do you care about what you can't slack
for guys not really joe what it is it's
not that i care about body count and i'm
going to sound like a complete [ __ ] but
it's like the quality of the person
because sometimes i don't mind but then
when i see the type of god i don't use
trump the person that you've just gone
with and i'm just kind of like see the
them yeah so when it comes to like
beating girls in that yeah you know man
i'm not really care like that like you
see a lot of girls i'm sure you know the
guys to be a certain whatever like guys
just want to get bust they're not you
know i'm trying to say so it's not a
thing of like oh this person is this
this kind of level quality whatever like
my name don't really
that's not a lot of man will cheat on
their girls which is mad with a dead
like they might have a 10 10 girl but
not cheating with a five five because at
the time they're just thinking with
their penis and they're just thinking
about the knot
really proud of this moment so there's
this really good looking guy at the end
of the bar once
so i sent some drinks
you said drinks yeah i said drinks to
you
yes i said the bomb and i was like look
send him drinks and the barman come back
and was like oh he rejected it right i
died inside a little
and then sent a bottle of champagne over
and then he walked then the guy came up
with two glasses and was like that was
really kind of you to offer a bar i
don't let women buy me drinks but i hope
we can toast together and i was like i
haven't played the game but you've got
games yeah yeah you better you finished
it nicely still but right you're sending
drinks to the random enough yeah
don't do that
well i did and we do there's women that
shoot the shot
i really that's still you know i said
that's a proper gangster move still
thank you well done that takes a real
boss in it so she's got some courage i
respect that michael so i'm gonna just
there waiting to yeah come on man she's
a g man ladies learn
learn from show you get me you know what
i like this guy you know what would you
do if i'd sit with two of your friends
when i'm getting to know you yeah
if i really like you i could look past
it really i'm trying to see but if i
just met you
and oh yeah my name's like are you a man
chop that i'll probably just learn i'll
just probably be cool with you so like
the strategy for women is don't let him
introduce you to the bros i don't want
to do that but you have to let us know
about it and if you've done it you're
gonna have to let me know that
eventually if you're taking man
seriously would you want me to directly
tell you you have to tell me would you
not prefer no but at what stage then
well my name after told me if if if my
man ain't told me and you ain't told me
you're not all sneaky when do i tell you
then because this is the thing what if
i'd done it i really like you and then
now i'm scared that i'm going to lose
you imagine i find that at the moment
said you know i'm not going to let you
know you like this drone but in 2020 i
was blowing it back out if he told me
that yeah and then i'll come to you that
and you knew this i'll fall away that
you didn't show me this one before oh
evil way we all lose well you're losing
it but honestly it's the best policy in
it i mean if it's me personally if my
mind's getting with the get a man's
chopped that thing back in a day i'm
sure man yo broski back in the day
that was my journey i've done that in it
so in my boys you get me they gotta show
me in it can't be on some sneaky thing
man what would you do if my ex was after
you can this beef in it though won't you
want me to do it
i mean
well i'm not gonna be like
if he wants beef with me then
i'm gonna try and avoid it for you also
you can hear because someone you
probably love once in a time but i'll
speak to him like bro like listen the
girl's mind now respectfully
she doesn't want you no more you gotta
let her go if he keeps coming if he's
coming for me i'm not coming for him so
if he's coming for me then i just gotta
do with it comes to me in it
do you know what i mean what would you
expect a guy to do probably that
actually
she's really buying what i'm saying you
know where what would you do if i wanted
to start an only fans why why i'll ask
you why like why do you want to start on
your phones make money what are you
doing at the moment though have you got
no job and you're just trying to yeah
well if i was just out here hustling
well and it's just like your only result
do you want your fans it's not the only
results
no man multiple streams of income on
netflix
what were you doing though sharing your
toes i knew you like toes no i don't
like toes but like then i can see toes i
don't care about that everybody can see
the toes but you're trying to show like
everything else nah i don't know anyone
seeing what i was what's my like bro
there's no way my girl is getting on the
fence sorry big up everyone has been the
only fans you don't do your thing but my
girl
no i'm your only fan i'm the only one i
see in that stuff
in a story
yes it's that ego thing it's not ego
thing it's just like
i don't want to share what's mine like
with other people like and also
my girl will never be in a situation
where she needs to be only friends for
money why have you got a pattern like
that yeah
if you're if you're with me and we're
together i've got you guys i'm trying to
say like so if you need help i would
help you or i'd help you look for a job
that you want you know i'm trying to say
that i don't need you to resort to only
friends have you always been like this i
feel like i really like the way you
answer the questions i've grown a lot
as i said like being on a long
relationship i've grown a lot and i
learned a lot before
i was not
this kind of guy like i was like my
friends will tell you toes will never be
in a relationship like i'll never
i'll never be vulnerable i'll never want
to commit to one person i mean like i
want to be dating different girls but
i'll never take any goal seriously or
try to be in a relationship with any
goal like i was not on that you know i'm
going to say like i don't know why i
just didn't care like that
do you think we've got chemistry yeah no
i feel like we're kind of vibing i feel
like we would have a good conversation
and a good friend as well yeah man i can
talk to you that actually i'm saying and
you're not too serious but you have
values as well like that's like things i
look for in a woman
nice yeah we do i wish you the best for
2022.
are you looking for a man in 2022 yeah
hopefully what's your type where where's
your touch by the way if you were stuck
with my exes that was so different so i
don't have like a specific type just
yes
you are actually i'd say over time okay
oh my god the date was good man i don't
feel like she really grilled me hard you
know she was quite nice it was a good
conversation i feel like we had a deep
connection so it's different from the
other ones you know what i'm trying to
say it's a good day cheers guys
yeah i think your second date's on the
cards no it was so hard to grill him
because i quite like him i'm not gonna
let i think i handled the grilling quite
well mankind i didn't really feel no
pressure yeah it was definitely one of
the best dates i've had for that day
i'll probably give myself
it's 10. yeah i'll slide this down okay
tell my ticket to the studio
i'm gonna give him a nine and he's got a
nine because i feel like he's honest he
seems like a good man he's a family man
that's all i want only six foot
[Music]
you